uh great first me can you hear me at the
back okay
yeah great uh so thank you to the
organizers for inviting me to give this
talk and thank you all for attending so
just a little bit about me my name is
kitchen i work as a data science manager
at a luxury fashion e-commerce
company called farfetch where i work on
large scale time series forecasting
and pricing optimization
when i can i also contribute to open
source and recently made some
contributions to the time series
decomposition modules and stats models
i'm also uh developing an online course
on the same topic feature engineering
request for forecasting
if you're interested please check it out
so what does this talk about this talk
is all about how do you convert a time
series forecasting task uh we're gonna
predict the future value of some
sequence or a set of sequences and
convert that into a tabular machine
learning regression task
and then that way we can use our our
classic models like random forests and
near regression
so my talk is split into two main key
themes one is just how do we do
forecasting when we're working with
tabular data
and secondly how do we build good
features once we're doing that
so firstly i'm just going to motivate
why we would want to use machine
learning
for time series forecasting
and i want to motivate that by way of an
example
so a couple of years back there was one
of these big forecasting competitions so
called m competition so this was the
fifth one the m5 competition and the
challenge here
was to predict the future value of a set
of retail products and so that the
company was walmart and the reason why
it was interesting was the the nature of
the data
so
in terms of there were over 30 000
product store combinations product id
store combinations
and so that means there were over 30 000
correlated time series
there was a hierarchical structure to
that data so a product id belonged to a
department a category
it could be allocated to a store and
then a state so on so there's a
hierarchical aspect to the data
each time series can be a varying length
so a product can come online at
different points in time
as you can see from the time series in
the bottom right there is no obvious
seasonality and trend
uh it's highly sparse and intermittent
uh exogenous variables would also be
thought to be quite important here like
the price of a product
promotional activity
and you'd expect multiple seasonal
patterns like uh
week week effects so the day uh weekends
versus weekdays the summers can be
different to the winter
and so you get multiple seasonality
and so it turned out for a problem like
this uh all of the top performing
methods in the competition were actually
quote unquote pure machine learning
methods
and actually light gbm was used in the
top solutions and it was better than all
of the standard statistical benchmarks
traditionally used in time series
forecasting like arima and exponential
smoothing
and so a machine learning approach is
able to learn across a large number of
related time series also take into
account exogenous variables
and you can also get a neat little side
effect if you're starting to use the the
standard regression models you can for
example get access to using sample
weights and you can use that in nifty
ways like giving more weight to recent
data if you wanted to do that
you can also use custom lust the custom
loss functions which was actually used
in the winning solution
and so these are some of the reasons why
you might want to use a machine learning
a model for forecasting
that doesn't mean you should neglect
simple statistical baselines though
because uh 92.5
of participating teams failed to be one
of the simplest statistical models
exponential smoothing and even the top
50 entries only beat exponential
smoothing by between 15 to 20 percent uh
depending on the level of granularity
you're looking at
and so you really have to make sure that
the uplift that you're getting from
using machine learning approach warrants
the additional complexity
so how do we do forecasting with machine
learning so let's say we start off with
our time series
and we want to predict uh
t plus one given that we're currently
sat at time t
so we want to create a table of features
and a target variable
and so as the target variable you want
to predict the sales so you just
directly use that as a target variable
and to start off with the features that
we want to create are from the past
values of the target variable because
you want to use
the values in the past to predict the
future
what you must do though is only use data
that you actually know
at the time of the target otherwise you
can leak data from the future into the
past and i'll show you several examples
of how this can quite easily occur
so we're going to create some features
from past values and the simplest things
that you can do is just directly use the
the previous values so if you're sat at
t and you want to predict t plus one
then use the value at t t minus one and
so on
these are kind of called lag features
and if you and so now you've created a
feature vector for for the next step
and you you do this for each value of
the target so now if you want to predict
the target variable at time t you'll use
the value at t minus one minus two and
so on
and so that way you create a set of
feature vectors associated with the
target variable obviously as you get
towards the end of the time series
you'll get some missing data because
there is a finite start
so this means you'll have features where
you derive
you derive the features from past values
of the time series itself i've shown you
some very simple ones here so called lag
features i'll show you some slightly
more complicated ones later
then you also have features where you
might know the values in the past and in
the future for example marketing spend
might be one you might know on a given
day how much marketing spend there was
and how you observe the sales and you
might also have a budget where you know
the value of the marketing spend in the
future so it's quite easy to include
that in your feature vector you just use
it directly
then you might also have features where
you only observe the values in the past
but you don't know them in the future
that typically happens with things like
for example the weather
perhaps rainfall affects the sales of
your product and you only know that in
the past
so what you have to do is find a way of
predicting in the future to put in your
feature vector
so one thing you can do is use an
alternative forecast so if you have a
weather forecast you can plug that in
directly
or you have to create your own naive
forecast where you might just predict
out the the previous value and if
neither of those are suitable for your
use case you can also use lagged
versions of say a weather related
feature so if you want to predict the
sales tomorrow you use the rainfall
today and just like we did for the
target variable you lag them
lastly one which you may not hear as
much about is actually so-called static
features they're called static because
they don't change
for a given time series and typically
they refer to some metadata about your
time series so when you're dealing with
multiple time series let's say you have
sales in multiple countries
then you'll actually have the static
feature different between time series
but within a time series it's the same
and so you can use that information to
try and train a model to learn the
differences between different groups of
time series for example
and so with that we kind of have a table
of data so we've got our features we
have a target
and then you can use uh everything in
blue there as training data we'll show
later how we encode the categorical
features and missing data
so you can now fit your model sk learn
style use whatever you want and you can
predict one step into the future
in practice you'll want to do multi-step
forecasting you you care about
forecasting more than just one step into
the future so how do you do that
so there are two main techniques to do
this one is called direct forecasting
and the other is called recursive
forecasting
so in direct forecasting you're going to
directly predict the value of the target
at time t plus one t plus two and so on
with the information you have at time t
so effectively you're using the same
features but you're creating different
target variables for each forecast step
so you end up training multiple models
with different targets
so let me just show you how that might
look in practice so as you're creating
the feature vectors you start off at
some time and we might use our lag
features again so we we create the we
populate a feature vector and if we're
going to forecast one step ahead we'll
create a target for that
another target for the second step ahead
and so on
and so now you have a single feature
vector and multiple targets
and you can construct your feature
vector for the next step ahead and so on
so you end up training a model on
effectively the same set of features
but you will give them different target
variables
and so when you plug in the feature
vector from the most recent time period
each model will give you a different
step ahead forecast
now this has the obvious disadvantage
that you have to train multiple models
so if you want to do a 28 day ahead
forecast you have 28 models
have fun putting that into production
so is there a simpler approach here
yes so with recursive forecasting you
only train a model once you train a
one-step ahead forecast model and you
use it repeatedly so let me show you how
that works
so you stand at time t you create your
features you train a model to predict
one step ahead like i showed before
and then you make a forecast but you
plug that forecast back into your target
time series
and then you recreate the feature vector
for the next step ahead and plug that
back into the model and so you're doing
a series of one step ahead forecasts
i'm going to show you what that looks
like on a tabular data set so imagine
you've already
dealt with your static features your
future known features and your future
unknown features and you've already
created your feature vector for the
future
now you just have to be concerned about
the features that you derive from the
target variable so let's just focus on
that
so for the doing the first step ahead
it's quite simple we can create our lag
features just by looking at the
historical data there
so that one's fine you can train a model
dot predict you've got a one step ahead
forecast
now you plug that back in and you create
the new feature vector using uh the
information from the forecast as well so
now the forecast is inputted into the
feature vector and it's plugged back
into itself
and that way you can forecast as many
steps ahead as you want
now this comes also with its own set of
drawbacks because
if you have any error or the model's not
very accurate then you propagate that
error as you're doing multi-step
forecasting
you're also only directly optimizing on
forecasting one step ahead your actual
problem is to forecast multiple steps
ahead so you're not actually optimizing
on what you care about but it is
computationally simpler to do
there's also some code complexity having
to go through this procedure
which is why later i'll show some good
libraries to help you do this
the last thing i'll talk about on this
topic is also how do we validate a time
series model or a forecasting model so
typically when we're dealing with
tabular data you just to randomly split
the data between a test set and a
training set
you can't actually do that in this case
because the assumption that allowed you
to do that traditionally for
classification and regression tasks is
that the rows are independent here
there's a time ordering to your data and
so the rows are not independent you
can't just shuffle them into a train and
test set this is because you might plug
values in the test set which are from
the past you might have values in the
training set from the future and so
you're using the future values to
predict the past and you'll have a very
bad estimate of how good your
forecasting model is
instead you need to split by time
and replicate the actual forecasting
process itself so let me just visualize
that for you so typically you'll order
your data
by time so you have the full data set
and then you split at some period so you
you pretend that you're sat at that time
point and you're having to
create your features at that point and
then predict over some value forward i'm
not sure if the colors are coming across
too well there
and then you move your time window
forward and then you have another fold
where you can train and test on but in a
way that preserves the time ordering so
you get an accurate estimation of the
performance of your forecasting model
so one of the things i really want to
highlight here is the difference between
doing a classification and regression
task versus a forecasting task despite
the fact we're still dealing with
tabular data because the workflows are
very different
um for a start as i showed earlier
if you're doing a train test split you
traditionally could do that just by
randomly shuffling now you have to care
about preserving the time
ordering when you create the feature and
target variable for regression and
classification tasks you could typically
create the entire feature and target
matrix before you even go to a near the
model
before you plug them into dot fit and
dot predict now if you're doing
recursive forecasting you're dynamically
building some values that go into the
test set at predict time
and so that's a big difference and has a
consequence for the next step that what
you do at predict time
so for regression and classification
tasks you typically just need the
trained model and then you have some
input and you get a prediction
not so for recursive forecasting because
you need not just a train model but you
also need to pass it the training set so
it can rebuild those features that it
derives from the target variable at
predict time so the way you serve the
model is going to be quite different
to just classification
and regression
lastly
the feature engineering is quite
different there are a set of specific
feature engineering methods for time
series and a bunch of data leakage
issues that you didn't have to consider
as much
uh when thinking about regression and
classification tasks so
with that i'll move on to the next
section and also make the suggestion
that rather than coding a lot of this
from scratch i highly recommend using
some time series libraries and i'll come
on to those later
so let's talk about how we build good
features for time series forecasting
so the area covers quite a wide range of
areas for time series so
feature engineering covers everything
from
how do you handle missing data and
outliers which have their own specific
techniques when you're dealing with time
series um how do you transform your time
series to potentially make it easier to
forecast like taking a log transform or
do you de-trend or de-seasonalize the
data first how do you handle categorical
features now
um you can extract a lot of information
just from the temporal part of the
problem things like uh taking stuff from
the calendar like the the the month uh
the week of the year et cetera holidays
you can also derive
features from the past values
of the target
and and other features
and also time series often contain trend
and seasonality which is quite important
and you might be interested in capturing
things like change points step changes
and seasonality and so you can create
nifty features to try and capture that
given the the time constraints i'm only
going to talk about some of uh some of
these which are commonly used and we're
actually used also in the uh
the winning solution for the m5
forecasting competition
so just as a principle that you should
always take away when working with time
series is when you're creating features
only use data that you actually will
know at the time of prediction
it sounds a lot easier to do
but then i'll show you that it can
happen in all sorts of ways where you
accidentally leak information from the
future into the past
so let's talk about a specific example
let's say you're trying to predict uh
the sales of multiple different products
so you have a table of data you've got
the product id
some advertising spend and the sails
and you've concatenated the data so
you've got i've tried to highlight the
the different time series with different
colors here but you've basically got
different time series concatenated in a
single table
and you want to predict uh the next step
ahead
so how do you first of all set up the
target variable now you're dealing with
multiple time series
uh if your table looks like this you can
just directly use
the sales column as as your target
vector the interesting thing to note
here is that uh you're now mixing
multiple different time series in in the
target vector the model doesn't know
uh that any given row is coming from the
same time series or even from
different time series all together so
that's one thing just to bear in mind
there
and so the first kind of simple class of
features you can create are just what
are called lag features
and this is where you're using the
previous values of the target and
feature features themselves logic here
being that the past values are the most
are the ones most likely to be
predictive of the future so just using
yesterday's value the day before
but also
seasonal lags are very common and this
is just a very quick and dirty way to
capture some seasonality if you know
your data has weekly seasonality then
include a lag of one week and i'll show
you that works quite well in an example
later
you might also use the lags of other
target time series so you might use the
the previous values of one product to
predict the future values of a different
product
you have to be very careful if you were
to do this because you create another
feature vector for each product so if
you've got a large category of products
catalog of products you probably don't
want to do this but if you've got a
small number of time series and you want
to model the dependence between them
this is an easy way of doing it
lastly the past values of exogenous
features can also be quite predictive in
particular to capture effects which are
distributed over time let me just give
you an example
let's say you have some degree of
marketing spend today that could impact
the sales today but it could also have
an impact on the sales tomorrow and the
day after and so on the effect is
distributed over time
and so you can also just use a series of
lags for say advertising spend to try
and capture that effect and sometimes
that's known as as distributed lags
so what does this look like when you're
actually building your table of features
as i've shown before you're just using
the past values to construct the feature
vectors in a way that you don't leak
information and you just slide your way
across uh we do some practice
effectively just shifting the column by
the amount of the lag you should be very
careful that if you dealing with a data
frame that looks like this if you do a
shift you don't want to accidentally
move information from one time series to
the other at the edges so do a group by
and then shift
so window features are kind of an
extension of lag features so rather than
just directly using the past values
you're going to compute a summary
statistic or function
over
several past values so you might take
the mean or standard deviation of the
last five values
that can be quite helpful to smooth out
any volatility you might have but also
if you're using the standard deviation
you can measure the volatility and use
that as a as a predictive feature
so once again what does that look like
on our on our table to build for
features in our target
you have to define some window size
and then you basically drag your window
across and compute your your features
one thing to note here is that after we
compute our statistics we are lagging
the value by one to preserve the the
time ordering here and to make sure that
we don't accidentally use values at the
same time to predict uh the target at
the same time hence the lag if we were
to just do pd.rolling.mean
uh the rolling average would be computed
so where we've got 34 it'll be along the
same row and so you'd be leaking
information at that time into your
features which you don't want to do
does that make sense
okay perfect
um
so a very common tactic here is to nest
uh several different window sizes
um so the the objective here is
basically to capture any differences in
different time scales
and so you just compute the the averages
or whatever statistics you're interested
in over various different time scales
for both the target and and features
i've seen both done
and then you will end up with
several features one for each each
window size
now uh the last one i want to show are
so-called static features and so these
are the ones which don't vary uh within
a time series but can vary between time
series
and so this typically refers to metadata
so here i'm showing product id
but you might also have say product
category
so a given product id might be of type
shorts
another one might be watches
so your data set might actually be a
bunch of time series and you might have
some shorts and some watches shorts
might be highly seasonable
and watches are not it'd be good to be
able to feed that information to the
model so that it knows that
there are differences between
groups of time series and as i mentioned
earlier just by looking at the target
vector especially if you're treating it
as a tabular regression problem the
model doesn't know that there's any
relationship between any data point you
have to put it in the feature
so very simple way of doing that is
actually targeting encoding which is
heavily used in classification and
regression tasks and so what you do
there is you will just group by your
categorical variable
and then just take the mean on the
training data
and so here we're just taking the mean
of say skew one over over its historical
time series and you do that the same for
skew two and then if the mean for skew
one is 30 then you just impute 30 for
wherever you source q1 and so forth for
sku2
before i move on does anyone see any
issue with this at all
so yeah one comment on how do you deal
with new data
yep
[Music]
so if the two values are the same then
the model effectively thinks the two
product ids are the same because you're
representing the
the product by its sales basically yeah
that's a good point
there's an ah
the mean is not detecting good for
seasonality that's correct but here
you're just trying to
create a numeric value for your features
so it's not necessarily an issue
perfect yes exactly
so
there's no leakage between the training
set and the test set that's fine because
you only use the training data to
complete your encoding so if you were to
test your model the error metric you get
is going to be reliable
but you are getting target leakage
because within the training set you're
using information from the future uh
in in previous values and i'll show you
a visualization of that
and so this can create some overfitting
to this particular feature
so let me just show you that so let's
say you've got your time series here uh
you've have some values in the past and
then you've split your data so train and
test
and you've got your product id there
you now just take the mean across your
training set and you're imputing your
your product id there right
so now think about what the model will
do if it's when it's training on say the
second time point
at that point in time
the model doesn't know about any of the
future values but because you've encoded
it using the mean over the whole
training set
it can for example infer that well i
know the time series is going to
increase because it already has that
information from the future
and so the model is going to say well
this is a very predictive feature
when in practice it may not be as
predictive as you think it is
so a small adjustment you can do is as i
said at the beginning only use the
information you'll actually have
available to you at that top point in
time
and so you would only use the data prior
to that point to compute the encoding
then
and then you basically have an expanding
window and so the encoding will actually
change
over time
and that way you're not leaking any
information from the future
into the past uh so now there's probably
another question on like how do you go
into the future when how do you compute
the encoding for future values
for one step ahead forecasting that
that's okay you're just gonna take the
mean over the whole training set prior
to that so you can create that feature
vector
if you're doing recursive forecasting
then you have to go through that whole
stick again so
you you train the model you make a
prediction one step ahead and then you
have to recompute the encoding so that
you're consistently creating the feature
in the same way as you're doing in the
training set as you are in the test set
if you were going to use
direct forecasting you could try just
projecting it out
or you have to preserve the uh
the time distance between the value that
you're predicting in the future and then
the window in the past that you're going
to take the uh the mean over the
training set over
so just some key takeaways i want to
give you from from this section is that
data leakage is a huge risk and it can
quite easily happen especially when
you're creating features uh from the
target or future unknown variables hence
you should only try and use information
that you actually know
at the time of the target and also the
handling of features can vary at predict
time depending on how you're going to do
multi-step forecasting
and so the code that you're going to
have to write and how you handle
features can be completely different
depending what you do
and so there are some useful libraries
out there that can help us do that
and so i just want to give you an
overview of some of those and give you
an example
so if you're just interested in taking a
data frame and creating a bunch of time
series features
you could use something like ts fresh
your feature engine feature engine uh ts
fresh basically computes a very large
number of different time series
statistics uh so you have time series
goes in statistics come out and they
have quite a lot there
if you're actually interested in doing
uh forecasting using tabular data with
whatever your favorite machine learning
model is whether that's light gbm or a
random forest
then both darts and sk time are
fantastic libraries that enable you to
do this the scope of those projects is
way larger sk time for example also
offers lots of cool feature engineering
techniques and transformers if you want
to create a nice neat pipeline
but they also enable you to do recursive
or direct forecasting and provide
wrappers around that so you don't have
to implement the
recreation of say lag features as you're
moving forward in time
also makes time series cross-validation
very easy as well
so i'm just going to show you an example
uh using darts because that's one i was
slightly more familiar with before
making this talk after talking to some
of the s time sk time contributors on
friday i highly recommend also looking
at sk time
so how do you how do you go about doing
forecasting with tabular data let's show
an example so imagine you have a time
series here this is just a monthly time
series of values it's actually their
passengers data set
and the one thing you'll need is a
wrapper around a data frame so you
import what's called the time series
darts internally uses these time series
objects just a lightweight wrapper
around a panda's data frame
and then it's the regression model that
you import that does all the heavy
lifting and implements
all the complexities around recursive
forecasting for you and then you can
import any regression model that you're
interested in from sklearn so here i'm
just going to use linear regression but
it can be whatever you want
and then the first thing you'll do is
wrap your
your data frame into a time series
object uh you can create a
holdout set so the last 24 points
are
held out and use the
everything
before that as training
and then it's in the regression model
itself where you're going to define the
lag features that you want you don't
have to create them beforehand in a data
frame then pass that
and the reason for that is because you
need to tell the model the logic of
how do you recreate those features and
so they're passed to the the regression
model class so here we're going to use a
lag of 1 2 and 12.
and then you specify which which
regression model you want to use in this
case it's just linear regression
and then you've got your model
object you can just hit dot fit on your
on your time series
uh and then dot predict and you specify
how many points into the future you want
to extrapolate to so here it's just 24.
and i did mention that just using a lag
of 12 can help capture the seasonality
you'll see that quite nicely here
and so that works quite well so just
using a lag of 12 for example
and so there i've shown you how to do
recursive forecasting using linear
aggression on a single time series and
only lag features what if you have
covariates
so here we might have additional things
like your future known features so you
might know your marketing spend in the
past and the future
you can also extract information from
the calendar which will be quite helpful
things like the the month and the year
the month in particular can help you
capture some additional seasonality
which might be specific for given months
maybe black friday occurs in a given
month quite useful to have
um so what do you do there well
you just pass that those features as a
pandas data frame uh and convert it into
a time series so in darts they call
these future covariates so uh on the
bottom there you've got futurecov equals
time series from dataframe df and i've
just sub selected those features so now
you've got a
time series object for your time series
and your covariates
and then you make one slight tweak in
the regression model darts allows you to
also specify if you want to have lag
features of your uh covariates so if i
wanted to do the lag of marketing spend
you can specify that directly uh
in that argument there in this case i've
just said don't lag it lag of xero
and then you just pass your covariates
at model.fit and then at mould.predict
you just say how many time points in the
future note that we're also passing the
training set as well as i mentioned
earlier which is a key difference
between classification and regression
tasks and then that's it you can do dot
predict and now you've
included features as well now let's show
you one last example which is slightly
more complicated
so it's quite typical you run a query
you pull your data
you have a timestamp you might have some
metadata about your product so you have
country the product id
and then you have your your target
variable in this case sales and you have
some features
how do you handle all of this uh so
darts has a a nice helper function
called from group data frame not sure
how clear that is from here
but it allows you to specify the group
columns uh which define your individual
time series so in this case it'll be
country and product id
you specify your time column
and the the value of the time series
which for the target time series will
just be y you do a similar thing for
your future covariates and what that
does
is it creates a a list of time series so
it'll transform your data from this view
to a list of lots of individual time
series which also just want to note here
that the time indexes for these time
series can also be different they don't
need to all be
indexed at the same time uh and
in the future covariates you'll also
have your features and there's a
one-to-one correspondence between
your your y's and your x's
and then uh
same same kind of stick you put in
model.fit you put all of your training
data there and your future coverage and
you're passing multiple time series now
under the hood the regression model is
building your features stacking them
together creating a tabular view that
you can then do model.fit and dot
predict recursively build
uh the features uh for each of your
individual times so you're getting a lot
of value here um from from using the
library to do that for you
and then at predict time you can say
well i'm only interested in making a
forecast for just these two individual
time series so i can specify that i just
wanted those particular two there at the
bottom during dot predict and then you
will just have a forecast for those two
time series
and yeah just a reminder so the model is
training simultaneously here on all of
your time series at the same time the
time indexes may not even be aligned
good luck doing that with arima
um and so i've shown you here that uh
how you can do recursive forecasting
with linear regression on many time
series with lag features and future
known features
i haven't shown window features because
you can't as far as i'm aware do that in
darts yet but you can do it in sk time
so just to conclude forecasting can be
treated as a tabular machine learning
kind of regression task and it can be
competitive
with more traditional statistical models
the feature engineering and machine
learning workflow is quite different for
time series forecasting
and forecasting has its own set of
feature engineering methods and concerns
around leaking data from the future
and there's more and more becoming
available in the pytho ecosystem so do
watch out for those libraries if you'd
like to learn more i'm creating a course
with solidadgali there's also going to
be a github repo with a bunch of free
materials associated with that uh some
references i used whilst building the
course
building the uh the talk the talk's
already been shared in the snack channel
fyi
and that's it do you have any questions
[Applause]
hi uh thank you for the talk um i would
like to ask about the if you can talk a
bit about the feature selection uh
process so for example you mentioned
these
you know that you can create like
multiple lags and like multiple windows
so for example if i create like like one
like two like three then like what uh
you know window one window two window
three so all of those effectively sort
of share the same information and become
like correlated what are the sort of
typical processes for you know for
selecting those features and like
dealing with that
okay so the multiple things you can do
here um
so
if i if you go back to say that the the
realm of regression and classification
sometimes you don't care so much about
doing feature selection
because regularization helps you out an
awful lot right so the reason you do
feature selection is just because you
want to reduce the amount of feature
engineering and simplify your pipelines
typically
if you don't care about that then just
use a model with some regularization
in other cases you can use so let's say
lag features right
you can use kind of more principle
approaches where you can look at say the
autocorrelation function
try and help you understand which lags
are the most important
lags to use
so for those who don't know the auto
correlation function tells you um how
much the time series is correlated with
itself at different lagged values of
itself so um
yeah that's basically it it's in a
nutshell so you can use other methods
like that you might have domain
knowledge as well certain lags might be
more important than others
um other things i've seen done is you
just use lasso on a one step ahead
forecast and then hope for the best that
that will extend for your multi-step
forecasting uh always at the end of the
day you should always benchmark using
time series cross validation to see the
performance after you do all of that
feature selection
another thing i'd say as well here is
that you want to distinguish
doing time like do you actually care
about forecasting and you just care
about the future or do you care about
understanding the relationship of your
future and the future because so i also
do work on on pricing optimization and
you just shift price into this right but
if you've got a bunch of correlated
features you can't just say okay i'm
going to take my model change the price
and that's going to be the change in
demand um and so it also really depends
on what you want to do there because
that's more about causality but a lot of
people will take a time series
forecasting approach
to understand the relationship between
one feature and and say demand for
example
um in the beginning when you're talking
about splitting your training in test
data right
um you alluded about the m5 that some
people used some kind of uh time
weighted or some weights or cross time
to basically discount really old data
and just concentrate on more present
data do you have any
kind of heuristic on what kind of
function to use
okay so so as far as i know i didn't see
that actually used in the m5 forecasting
competition it was just an idea that i
had myself that uh having access to
sample feature
to the sample weights uh allows you to
do that if you want to do so for example
let's say a global pandemic occurs and
you want to and that changes your sales
distribution you might want to give more
weight during
to your model during a specific time
horizon and the sample weights will
allow you to do that right but how do
you smooth do you smooth it out or do
you say anything before you know march
2020 i'm going to ignore or do you want
to kind of have like a nice transition
um
honestly i don't know the way i would
approach that is potentially looking at
having some kind of ex like a set of
weights that decays exponentially as you
get back in time make sure the weights
sum to one
uh would be one way of doing it and then
you can probably have a parameter about
how quickly that exponential function
decays okay thank you
hi thank you for your talk
would you recommend window lags and
direct likes to use in one time series
experiment
as in would you use them both at the
same time both features at the same time
um i'd say you have to try and see so uh
in the m5 forecasting competition when i
looked at some of the solutions using
light gbm both were used
um
but in practice you just got to see what
what what works
but yeah
and so regarding this windows la
windowed lag
in your experience i'm enough to handle
any seasonality effects even long term
because like i get that
[Music]
like a seven-day windows could capture
weekly seasonality but if you also know
you have some yearly seasonality you
probably won't have a
200
365 day
window
so
in that case should the seasonality be
removed before applying
the model or what would you do uh it
depends what you're trying to achieve
there because
i mean
i would avoid using very large window
size as well because you end up cutting
a lot of the data at the beginning of
the time series if you were to do that i
mean you should really be capturing
seasonality uh using other features uh
rather than trying to capture them by
changing your moving average the size of
your window
thank you
just to expand on that as well i mean
there are a few ways you can also deal
with seasonality
you might actually so there are a set of
methods called time series decomposition
methods like stl which will allow you to
so deseasonalize the data first and then
you
you know there's a couple of interesting
points there so you could deseasonalize
the data and then you're just modeling
trend and noise right and then you add
the seasonal component back in
that can be quite good if you want to
use tree based models because if you do
have significant trend in your data
remember trees cannot extrapolate right
like it's a step function
and so typically you might think about
de-seasonalizing and detrending training
model predicting and bringing that in
afterwards or using a separate forecast
for the seasonality in the trend and so
there's a whole like swiss army knife of
methods that you could use for this kind
of stuff
um if you were going to
you were talking about your forecasting
for the independent variables have you
ever considered doing the instrument
free influence
for that so i didn't quite get the
instrument free inference so you know
how you you could use like an instrument
variable but instead you estimate the
instrument variable so have you ever
tried that what do you mean by an
instrument variable sorry um so when you
don't have the knowledge of one of the
independent variables and then you could
you know do like a two stage least
squares regression
and if you can't do that for whatever
reason then you can set parameters
um on a confidence interval and then
take some average of that
or
i can explain no i'm not going to
pretend like i've understood the
question i'm sorry maybe we can catch up
afterwards yeah sorry
how do you deal with seasonality that
wanders around the calendar a bit like
um easter
so that you typically just do like you
can many things you can do one is you
just have like a
a one hot feature so you know is easter
is an easy one
uh or if you have like something away
you might have a set of your holidays
and you just say is holiday zero one is
a very easy way of dealing with those
kind of things
thank you very much question uh that's
all we had time for but
i'm sure question will be around for
more questions thank you